film about Miles Davis but it's not a
biopic it's a clever way of letting us
into his world as having somebody who's
literally trying to get into his world
physically and also to explore it in
order to write about it you and McGregor
is a reporter on a mission in miles
ahead and in 2017 he'll take on a
drastically different role Lumiere in
Beauty and the Beast how does that work
today do they let you on fire how do you
play a lot well I don't know if I meant
to say well we're we're animated mainly
and then there's a sort of live-action
bit towards the end component to it yes
it's a bit of both so I didn't have to
deal with any real flames but I get to
sing a great song
be our guest the the great number that
Lumiere sings in the film you'll be our
guest we our guest be our guest the
actual shooting the film was done that
was great we had some Surry in mcallen
and emma thompson stanley tucci we're
some great great actors and it was fun
to be part of that and you know it was
great it was as much fun like off behind
the scenes as it was on
you